The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
AMIT GANDHI: This
is the container.
What happens in this, is
biogas gets produced in here.
It goes out the tube
through this set of tubing,
and into this
container to hold it.
This is just clamped off.
And when you unclamp
it, you should
be able to get biogas
from this and light it.
This has only been going for
a week and a half, or so.
So it may be producing biogas.
If you play with this, you
feel some suction on there.
But I don't know how much
gas this one produced yet.
I've been keeping it upstairs
because upstairs is way
warmer than downstairs
in D lab, so, yeah,
when we're done with
ours, we're going
to put them upstairs, as well.
The base looks
something like this.
So the first thing we have to
do is measure out 12 inches
by 7 inches from here.
And each of your
groups of three is
going to have to cut
one of these out.
So let's start by measuring it.
I'm going to run up and
grab a completed one.
[INAUDIBLE] so you guys can see.
Should probably
go the other way.
So he gets it.
So you want to measure
it 2 inches from here
and 3 to 1/4 inch or
AUDIENCE: 3 and 1/2.
AMIT GANDHI: 3 and
1/2 inches from--
AUDIENCE: OK and then
you think [INAUDIBLE]
where's the [INAUDIBLE]
Yeah [INTERPOSING VOICES]
REBECCA SMITH: Basically,
your only ingredient
in the biogas digester,
is this slurry.
So for your container, you'll--
for us, we're going
to fill this 3/4 full.
And the ratio of water to human,
animal, or vegetable waste
is three parts water to
one part [INAUDIBLE]..
And so that is one
thing that might make--
basically, that's a factor
you'll want to consider.
We were thinking of putting
in a biogas digester where
I was in Tanzania,
but their water supply
dries up a few
months a year, which
meant that just to get
water for their family,
they would have to
either pay more or walk
a really far distance.
So something like this,
would be a lower priority.
And there's a good
chance that it
would dry up and stop working.
And after that, it's really
hard to get it going again.
So the three things
that are really
important for a biogas system
are a good supply of manure,
having a hot enough
temperature, and having
a good supply of water.
So if you have
those three things
it's a really good solution.
But if one is missing,
then it will be tricky.
So someone want to dig in.
[LAUGHTER]
Ooh, it's ripe.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
Less terrifying than
you should expect.
REBECCA SMITH: Oh,
it's nice and dry.
AUDIENCE: OK, so kind.
Are we doing more than one
REBECCA SMITH: Yeah,
we're doing [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: Cold or hot water?
Lukewarm, oh.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Is that good enough?
A little more, less?
REBECCA SMITH: No, we only
want two quarters full.
So you could do a
little tiny bit more.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
stuck to my jeans.
[INAUDIBLE]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Then we need to hot
glue the bottle to
Oh, really?
Another, we need another
piece like that, right?
That goes.
REBECCA SMITH: [INAUDIBLE]
surprisingly well.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
REBECCA SMITH: I'm
pretty impressed with us.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So I think this is where the
other tubing, the clear tubing,
is supposed to go.
AMIT GANDHI: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Like
through here, right.
AMIT GANDHI: Need to make
sure this is sealed first,
for whatever.
REBECCA SMITH: OK, so we
need another piece of tubing.
And hot glue down [INAUDIBLE]
to the [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: I feel like the white
[? tape ?] should be smaller.
It should be floating.
I feel like the tube should
be less tall because it's
kind of in the way right now.
Yeah.
REBECCA SMITH: So one thing
that you can do with the heat
sealer, is make a soda stack.
So this is used for solar
disinfection of water.
So it's one way that
you can purify water.
What you do, is
you can fill any,
basically, clear plastic
container with water.
And then you leave it out in the
sun for about six hours or so.
And it will kill the
bacteria that's in it.
So you might still need to
filter it if it's turbid.
But as one step, that's
actually pretty effective.
So actually a D-lab alum,
MIT alum, called Sean Frayne,
his company is
called [? Haddock ?]
and they produce these.
So an alternative would be to
just fill maybe a plastic water
bottle, or this is one.
But it uses more
material than this so
would be more expensive.
And it's not super easy to
fill if you're pouring water
from something.
So what he came up
with, is just this bag.
Basically, you can
fill the water here.
So it'll just go in
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
REBECCA SMITH: Yeah, so
there's a smaller bag here
that has a hole in it.
We actually, in
the last session,
spent a while figuring
out exactly how
the different parts work because
it's a pretty clever design.
And then, so basically,
you fold it down
and then the water
is sealed in here.
And then after
your six hours, you
can just pour it
out pretty easily.
So it's a pretty clever design.
And this is something that
you can make in the field
to like every time, I think
Amy brings a heat sealer
on most of her trips.
Because there are just
a lot of useful things
that you can make.
I worked on a pouring dispenser
for my D-lab design project.
And we did something
kind of like this,
where it's like this, but
it's just a one-way valve.
So the idea isn't that you'll be
able to get it out afterwards.
But this was a really
low-cost way for us
to store the chlorine,
and then keep people
from getting it out.
Because we didn't want anyone
to be able to siphon it out
or tamper or anything like that.
Another thing you can do.
So this is a drip
irrigation kit.
And the way this works, is you
would fill it up with water,
and then you'd have
a tube coming out.
And from that tube,
are many little straws.
And you can direct a
small amount of water
straight to your crops.
So it's a much more
effective way of irrigating.
And it uses a lot less water.
And someone who I've
worked with in Tanzania,
named Bernard, he
has actually made
his own heat-sealing
machines, like this.
And so he can make
the tubes that
would come out of this,
just from a heat sealer
and locally available
plastic rather than having
to buy that or import it.
Another thing you can do to
seal something like this,
if you have male and
female pieces like this,
you can take some rubber
and make a washer.
And what you do is, have
a rubber washer layer
then a plastic or metal washer.
And then you could
have your plastic bag.
Basically, this
piece is a way to--
and then on the
other side, you'd
have another rubber
washer, plastic washer.
And then you could have a
sealed connection there.
Just as an example of
something else you could do.
A way to connect a bag like
this to something else.
So the things we have
that you can try out.
So this machine and this
one work the same way.
It's cool to the
touch, but basically,
when you push it down,
you'll see a light go on,
and it makes a click.
And then it just
melts the plastic.
And you can vary
the heat level here.
So in some cases, like for
the [INAUDIBLE] bag like this,
you might have some
seals where you
want it to go through
two bags, but not three,
or something like that.
So you can adjust the
level so that it will only
melt through two and
leave the other untouched.
And yeah,
AUDIENCE: Are you
saying that like
REBECCA SMITH: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So are you
saying that this part?
[INAUDIBLE]
So you can tell the kind
of, so this edge of the bag
is this thing.
Yeah
AMIT GANDHI: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And then with this
edge it goes to the little.
To the small, yeah.
And so when I do this then,
essentially what happens
is, that I prevent water
from coming in from here.
Because when water hits here,
this part is stuck there.
So the other side of this tube,
is one side of this one bag?
The other side of this?
Yeah, this goes into the bag.